Snoop Dogg just came out and said he had
a billion streams and he only made
45,000 which is crazy artists and all
genres of music should team together and
and fight that because it's our art we
should be compensated way more than a
billion streams $45,000 it was a point
in time where you sell a million records
and you see a million dollars back then
we had CDs it might have cost me $300 to
press up 1,000 CDs I'm selling them for
$10 a piece you do the math now you put
it out it hits the world immediately you
know with the streams and the whole
internet thing a lot of artists now are
just paid out through streaming but I
don't think it's really fair numbers
that artists get from the streaming
platforms at all